[Musik]
hallo herzlich willkommen so verließ
wels wir waren wieder unterwegs auf der
messe in essen er was es mit dem boxen
hier auf sich hat erfahrt ihr gleich
zuerst einmal möchten wir ein bisschen
was über die messe erzählen und bleibt
auf jeden fall dran denn am ende gibt es
ein richtig cooles tolles großes
gewünscht
[Musik]
also die messe in essen war wirklich
eine ganze sparte tandberg wir hatten
unseren stand in einer eigenen halle war
richtig groß und insgesamt waren 18.000
besucher 318.000 kannst du das vorstelle
ganz waghäusel war da ja ich niemals
gedacht dass so viele menschen kommen um
mich zu sehen waren sehr hammer wie
fühlt man sich so ja ich war am anfang
war es ein bisschen schwer
ja und dann ging es so leicht und schön
also wir beobachten den ansturm ja immer
so hinter dem vorhang und ich muss sagen
jedes mal stehen wir sogar alle haben
gänsehaut und es muss man immer zwei
drei tränchen verdrücken das einfach der
hammer wie so viele menschen vor unserem
tor warten bis es tor aufgeht und dann
rein stimmen als 1 gegen alle und alle
halten alle altersgruppen von null bis
85 ja aber alles 90 leute ums deutsche
sind wir sind russen sind alle alaba saß
schwarz-weiß gelten alle gehörlose
vertreten und wirklich gigantisch ich
habe dort wieder hat den ganzen tag
gekocht gebacken wir haben essen
verteilt murat hat sich immer sehr gut
um die zuschauer gekümmert hat kostenlos
getränke verteilt auch ehrlich ich muss
ehrlich sagen ich glaube die leute haben
das ganze eintrittsgeld allein zum stand
an und so stand wieder reingeholt sagen
darf egal wir haben mehr verteilt essen
getränke gab es funktionale und für
jeden da muss sich jeder auf seine
kosten gekommen
nachts ist immer wichtig auf messen dass
die leute herkommen ihren spaß haben
erst erleben und etwas geboten war
wieder so gigantisch also ich kann es
immer noch nicht ganz verstehen wie es
funktioniert aber es funktioniert mit
der hypnose da sitzen sie alle in der
reihe und sind plötzlich hypnotisiert
auf schnipseln reagiere und machen
wirklich das was der last also schon
gigantisch leider wurde mag auch dabei
leider denn mag war dabei ganz offen ich
werde dich nicht los geben ich werde
diesen mann liebt dich sein
der wirklich einfachen decken so sind
einfach alle haben gedacht er war du
weil er kommt im karohemd warum
funktionieren kann glaubt er
da ich in seinem leben einfach nicht
glücklich und viel zu schön dich zu
sehen um ich dann das wunder zu machen
ich glaube ja und dieses mal war auch
die entweder dabei islam hat torten
modelliert am deko back stand bei uns
und hat gezeigt wie man von dem modell
ihr schokolade und so weiter umgeht die
zuschauer konnten fragen stellen auch
mal was ausprobieren wir hatten auch
eine torte da wo man drauf
unterschreiben konnte die war auch
richtig cool und direkt neben der esll
emden war ein stand wo die in kanada hat
auch die puk geräte gezeigt ein bisschen
vorgeführt und sehr hat seine zuschauer
die kennen das alle schon was soll ich
das nämlich ist es ist keine kraus waren
schon er ist einfach die leute zu
unterhalten sonst gucken japan fühlen
dass es die fragen stellen und das ist
für mich eine messe haben das schlimmste
was gibt es eine messe moment geben sagt
normalen zu werden immer die gleichen
stellen es ist nämlich klar die leute
wollen sein finanziert werden aber
weiter genau aber ist herr unterhalten
und dann erst dann ist es für alle die
kohle ist manchmal noch da war
wir waren uns die abba barbara müsse
ihre arbeit machen willst ich hab ja
baracke gewachsen navara streuselkuchen
ja aber weil noch da war war der daniele
dann hier lesen freund von uns aus
hamburg den haben wir vor einiger zeit
kennengelernt und dieses mal war also
erst mal bei uns auf der messe mit dabei
und zwar mit dem trend newsstand aber
derart selektiv es in der stunde
wir wollen jetzt dass du das ist das ist
kein produkt platz ja das straße die wir
bekommen nichts ab und nix oder
wenigstens noch einmal gekriegt ja aber
das ist billig ist ein ganz ganz cool
es ist ein kleines familienunternehmen
ja was macht dann jene besonders er habe
ein papa in hamburg und er hat ein
italienisches restaurant in ostrava
damals war ich noch mal soll das
besondere an daniel ist würde ich mir
vielleicht ganz erzählen ganz nah ich
hasse
wenn menschen lebensmittel durch
deutschland und pakete verschicken lebt
mehr module zur markt kaufen kannst
neben eigentlich völlig ohne unter den
top boxen zu verschicken kenner
schwachsinn wirklich welt ist in sachen
überall bekommt sich mal ein salat mit
dem paket zugeschickt zu bekommen wenn
der salat nebendran ist also eigentlich
nichts und wir bekommen immer täglich
anfragen von welchen box hersteller und
ja manchmal doch jemand meist auf dem
bug box ist vielleicht auch sinnvoll
wenngleich das ist behoben ist nicht
gibt s nicht gibt man macht sinn aber
aber sich rezept der also 1 1 ist menü
durch deutschland schicken zu lassen
denn die schwach sind schauen sie
dagegen gewehrt aber dann jeder macht
wirklich was ganz ganz anderes ja und
zwar ist die brandnooz box muss man kurz
erklären sagt ja eigentlich schon der
name
da kommen produkte rein die wirklich
brennt news sind oder produkte die es
einfach nicht überall gibt dh der kanäle
gibt auch zum beispiel startup
unternehmen also ganz frisch gegründeten
unternehmen tollen neuen produktideen
er hat die möglichkeit sich am markt um
bis hin zu etablieren und sich
deutschland wie kann ich genau und dann
kommt das alles in der box und man kann
das ganze abonnieren man kann es auch
einmalig bestellt man kann es einfach
mal ausprobieren und dann ist das ganze
in der box einmal habe ich hier eine
normale box da gibt's auch die gourmet
borges dann gibt's also gibt's kategorie
vegan box wir haben jetzt eine kühlbox
dies auch richtig cool wird dann per
express dann auch verschickt das sind
auch kühlakkus drinnen die kann man
selber da noch weiter benutzen
ich tu dir auch wieder folgen auf die
farbe wieder benutzt das heißt ihr habt
kein unnötiges bloß material
ich bin gar nicht alles zeigen denn das
ist ja auch sein kleines bei sachen
überraschung zum beispiel butter mädels
mit grapefruit habe ich noch nicht
getrogen
und so der gefallen ihm her say you say
you ich liebe die meisten samstags
meisten ja eigentlich sagen wir immer
nicht samstags weil es so toll ist aber
egal geschafft und können wir gegen
absage kauft und bei dem ein haupt das
wissen auch die zuschauer holen wir mal
ein ding was noch nie probiert haben
bloß durch gucken uns die regale an und
sagen okay dieses produkt haben wir noch
nicht gesehen wo genau das heißt wir
haben im einkaufswagen ein produkt was
wir nicht kennen
und ja wir sind aus welt ist einfach
eine geniale geschichte
und so vielen monaten der andere
geschmacksrichtungen ganz neues bundes
tolle ist bei der bread news box bekommt
immer sachen zugeschickt die gibt es
noch gar nicht genannt teilweise wolf
startup sie kein geld haben sich in den
märkten und in die regale einzukaufen
und ihr müsst es einfach bewerten ihr
müsst einfach sagen wir gesammelt und
dann gibt es ein magazin dabei werden
auch teilweise dann die produkte oder
die hersteller erklärt und erläutert er
sein rezept ideen mit dabei alkohol
porträt ziehen jeden fall ist könnte
jedoch eine bewertung denn verdient dann
wäre es natürlich auch ganz wichtig was
war gut was war vielleicht nicht so gut
damit sie eben auch wissen welche
produkte sie in zukunft mit rein legen
können und ja das kann man dann einfach
mal ausprobieren und ist dann wirklich
sehr sehr viele startups unterwegs wenn
nicht muss dass auch hier sehr viele und
wir sind unternehmen eine möglichkeit
wie gesagt sich mal zu zeigen was ihr
auch gleich auch nicht wichtig dass 90
prozent der neuen produkte in
deutschland auf den markt kommt nach
einem jahr verschwinden ja also nur
eines im video mal erklärt wenn er
wirklich als zu 100% produkte entwickelt
und 19 90 prozent der produkte
verschwinden wieder aus dem regal
etablieren weil oftmals marketing wird
also geld fürs marketing
oft sind einfach die großen schon zu
groß und die kleinen haben keine chance
groß geworden und da finde ich das echt
ganz cool weil man lernt neue produkte
keine neue firmen kennen und hat einfach
mal was neues was man sonst vielleicht
nicht kaufen wird und es ist eine
überraschung also ich könnte sagen zum
beispiel milch kein alkohol oder wie ist
genau oder ihr seid irgendwie intoleranz
gekommen
und wie gesagt die kennt ihr noch nicht
dass ich immer eine überraschung
und was ist dabei ja ja und dieser stand
also brandes war bei uns mit auf der
messe und zwar auch richtig cool da
konnten meine zuschauer dann das rad
drehen und auch was gewinnen und einfach
mal ausprobieren die produkte anschauen
zwei direkt neben einer signierstunde
ich muss dazu sagen ich habe nicht so
viel vom daniela und von den anderen
gesehen weil die signierstunde ziemlich
voll war also auch dieses mal stand
wieder tausende menschen bei uns und ich
habe wirklich schon im hotel zu hause
und immer in den wald
aber einmal hatte ich eine halbe stunde
und habe eine halbe stunde nur
autogramme vorgeschrieben damit später
eben in der signierstunde alles bisschen
schneller gehen und ich muss euch noch
kurz was zeigen dass man sich jetzt noch
zeigen ich sag ja immer bringt mir bitte
keine geschenke und ich will auch keine
geschenke von euch aber oftmals stehen
dann kinder vor mir mit so großen
leuchtenden augen und bringen mir dann
doch was selbst gemachtes mit und ich
hatte diesmal wieder ein paar bilder und
briefe die ich auch alle gelesen habe
ich hab's auch auf instagram gezeigt und
diesmal war was richtig kreativ es dabei
nicht sagt jonas war da mit seiner mama
und jonas sagte rosalie ich habe dir was
gebastelt habe ich gedacht was machst du
denn gebastelt sagt deine küche ist doch
noch nicht fertig ich hab dir der küche
gemacht und hier hat er jetzt meine
küche die sallys welt da drinnen ist
seine mama die mit dem pferdeschwanz das
bin ich weil ich die haare immer
zusammen habe in der küche und hier
steht er jonas ist echt schön backofen
habe ich einen kaffee immer ich glaube
kam im schilde halle nur ja ich stelle
der kaffeemaschine und es ist echt
richtig süß lieber jonas nun alles
vergessen
jonas haben mich vergessen denkt
wahrscheinlich mehr wort krieg eine
eigene küche wo graz 5 minuten
er wollte einfach dass ich mit ihm und
seiner mama alleine backe und ich finde
die kirche so wunderschön die kriegt auf
jeden fall einen platz in meiner neuen
küche daher packe ich dir jetzt wieder
ein und nehmen sie dann mit mir vor was
kaputt geht richtig schön viele vielen
dank und auch danke an alle die da waren
das war wirklich wieder wunderschön und
ich hatte einfach so tolle zwei tage
diesmal waren es nur zwei und es ist
jedes mal ganz toll
ja also richtig genial oder ja was mir
noch ganz wenig zu sorgen auch allgemein
bitte bitte schickt uns keine pakete
seine geschenke geschenk wirklich alles
schreiben blick ganz gut
wir möchten keine kostenlosen
staubsauger keine keine gagen hat prima
zu probieren wir möchten wirklich nichts
geschenkt haben
nix und zu schwer und zu hause also
unsere wohnung die platz schon aus allen
nähten alles steht voll und das wäre
einfach zu schade wir haben alles in
jeder farbe bietet und einmal in groß
und klein sorge bestehe aber ist immer
zurück zur messe die messe war für uns
auch wirklich gigantisch zwar auch
dieses jahr die letzte messe auf der wir
im eigenen stand bahn die nächste messe
wird der erste ifa sein da bin ich aber
nicht mit meinem eigenen stand von daher
war es echt also gibt es in berlin immer
noch gern im september ging am ende
nimmt österreich so wie es ja auch noch
irgendwie genau aber halt nicht mit
messer stand juni frei vox im augen
meist gar nicht mehr geben eine
autogrammstunde für das findet ihr hier
jetzt mal das ist meine heimat sagt noch
mal raus murat überall hinein also
vielen dank dass ihr alle auf der messe
war und jetzt gibt's noch ein
gewinnspiel und wartet daniele gesagt
weil es eben auch so gut gefallen hat
bei uns das ok richtig coole leute
richtig tolle location gute stimmung
er möchte auch gerne etwas gutes für
mich und meine zuschauer tun und zwar
verlost er 200 müsst euch mal überlegen
200 dieser kühlboxen dieser brandnooz
kühlboxen deswegen habe ich jetzt auch
gar nichts war ganz verraten was man
alles brillen steckt wenn das soll hier
eine überraschung
und wenn ihr bei dem gewinnspiel
mitmachen wollte und die brotbox
gewinnen wollt dann könnt ihr einfach
eine e-mail schreiben an britneys ex
ellis welt.de und da könnt ihr dann eure
daten eintragen wichtig ist nur dass ihr
eine adresse eintragen
das ist eine kühlbox und die muss eben
verschickt werden und dann am nächsten
tag sofort entgegen genommen werden das
heißt eine adresse die erneut 20 oder 30
mai auf jeden fall auch gegen und gegen
genommen werden kann
das paket ja soweit kein deutscher
richtiger sollte egal ihr wisst was ich
meine
genau das ist ganz wichtig und falls ihr
das gewinnen wollt einfach
e mails schreiben und dann wird das
ganze verlost ihr bekommt dann der e
mail zurück ob ihr dabei waren oder
nicht
und ja und wie gesagt es ist keine wir
kommen nicht dafür dass man rede ist in
toller form einer den käse und sohn des
unternehmensratings wohl ihr könnt euch
mal auch mal gucken was die machen oft
in ihrer website und ich bin echt cool
dass du daniele unternehmen unterstützt
um die start ups unterstützt und ja
deswegen machen wir auch mal überdenken
in der prüfung auf jeden ganzem herzen
ja ganz toll
ja er ist halb italien auf wo siehst du
wusstest du dass weiß dass jemand weil
es keine zeit nicht halber italiener
halber ich darf jetzt ein ganz alter
nehmen und ich glaube und und die hälfte
er ist deswegen interessieren
doch nämlich um die isländer er ist halb
isländer halb italiener so ein bisschen
also ich war für euch hat dieses video
gefallen im anschluss seht ihr noch ein
paar richtig coole bilder von der messe
märz viel spaß gemacht schön dass ihr
wieder mit euren ganzen babys da war es
eine baby gekuschelt auf der in meiner
küche nicht mehr mit der schleife ich
habe von keiner modus prinz weiß dass
jemand der das nicht so trauen
naja egal aber ist nicht immer ist
nämlich vielen dank für all die
längliche und denn den spaß den wir uns
hatte muss vielleicht noch dazu sagen
und so eine messe ist echt für uns sehr
anstrengend also wir sind wirklich
tagelang unterwegs tage lang von zu
hause weg von meinen kindern ohne pause
ohne brot nein aber es ist schon
körperlich auch sehr anstrengend für
morgens bis abends präsent sein
da stehen kochen backen
autogrammeschreiben aufbauen abbauen
aber ich mache wirklich sehr gerne und
mit ganzem herzen das macht einfach
super viel spaß menschen kennenzulernen
und ich habe auch wieder einige erkannt
melek ganze ist zum beispiel wusste ich
von facebook sind einfach so viel mit da
oder die vanessa die ribery ach gott
jetzt über das richtig gut und richtig
gerade da kommt ja auch sogar der tom
und die anderen haben die ramona
wiedererkannt von der letzten messe sehr
schön auch bekannte gesichter natürlich
die ganzen gruppen und facebook gruppen
muss ich wieder da dazu sehen das echt
schön automobil hat einmal genau das
haben wir bekommen einmal einen schub
bekommen
damals in meiner handtasche ich habe
keine lust auf richtig kohle dank aber
bitte schenkt uns nicht okay also viel
spaß beim also viel erfolg beim make
gewinnspielen ich drücke euch die daumen
und wer ist ihr das gedacht hat nächsten
wahl und alle sell on tour termine
findet ihr auf meiner homepage
[Musik]
[Applaus]